he's not going to win unless I get out
there and throw events like this and
people show up and then take that
feeling with them and they go home and
spread it around their neighborhood
their block
zila it on that
this is a campaign election that we eat
you can sit on your computer all day and
share articles and comment and be united
but to get 300 people in a room together
and realizing this person lives up the
street for me this person is my neighbor
we can meet up this saturday or next
Saturday and we can go flyering or we
can make phone calls it's much more
empowering and I think it holds a lot
more people accountable to actually
making choices in taking action and
doing things
people in our believe
my goal is if I can convince my parents
that he's a good candidate then I've
done my part you know I think if
everyone went home and that supported
Bernie Sanders and talked to their mom
or dad or grandma grandpa someone who's
sort of on the fence like if we can
change all those minds that's a pretty
wide net we're casting so it's
definitely the most inspired I've felt
in politics of them probably ever